welcome to the CEO playing x 69 AGG from
Spain lots of spanish players here ok i
should have played night 85 actually
castles was a bitter bit too quick but
ok it's not a big problem I'm regrouping
the night to be 6 this is one of the
possible ways to play this slow d3 set
up through be three now thats that's a
uncommon some way to maybe before you
okay so the Queen side is relatively
closed yes night c4 you're going to play
maybe I get in a five even here so
Knight d4 first you plot this right into
the center yeah f5 is a very loose move
so I must be must be cautious Queen to
h5 and those kind of things can can
happen really quickly so ok he's running
right into the small yeah should I play
a five at the moment I control therefore
so probably I should of course this long
diagonal Martha can be can be tricky ok
let's get this work involved okay now f4
is a possibility but I can take with
check only to wait on f4 so this this
must be ok I said this must be ok 15 you
here hmm ok check
I can actually promote that take take
there anyway now I'm threatening Bishop
h2 queen age for work g2 with the total
sacrifice
yeah but night a queen h4 sir is still
quite quite good
if I take it now and at the end i play
Bishop is Sam neither this must be
winning it really must be winning Queen
takes Bishop 32 Bishop e7 group chicks
is also now this Bishop b5 / should be 5
coming can maybe this is the easier way
to play Bishop g7 just this bottom it
takes you five you can take with the
rook know where fg8 okay okay
yeah of course this is a very dramatic
position yes but if we take particular
day you can take here so our wait wait
wait I can't I can do the sack I can do
this and now I cannot take here and if I
click here this Bishop b4 i actually had
a total hallucination him
mm-hmm I thought I can take on c3 I
don't ask me how I came to this
conclusion
oh this line is really totally sucks how
can you lose this game I mean how bad
how bad must the opponent play that I
actually win it unbelievable Wow now
there's not even a play will move
something sought to to try to retake him
or whatever
black resins really really great of
course if I can do anything around you
can really do anything even d 5s winning
Queen g3 is also totally winning check
rook g2h actually the move that wins you
know taking first and queen takes root g
eight is over of course yeah I sometimes
serene I already think I'm the biggest
idiot on earth that was pretty think I
Oh looky five I can be tricky then he
did this even hear ya i can i can click
King jet for example go out of this and
and again yes no move whatsoever the f
bonus running it's all the winning it's
all winning oh and the only thing that
knot winds is what a plate this is
really remarkable look at Duke see to it
sir even this is winning check now like
black has a pawn and still a big attack
the F phone is running its minus 2 that
great really great ok thanks for
watching